in 1985 it only took four words to
rocket dolph lundgren to international
stardom a Soviet punching machine Ivan
Drago the towering antagonist of rocky
for Lundgren made a serious impression
in the years since it's been revealed
that he only got into movies on the lock
as his master's degree in chemical
engineering probably would have opened
up employment options for him in a
different field
fortunately Hollywood has been pretty
good to the kickboxing chemist and if
you ever wondered what ever happened to
Dolph you may be surprised to know that
he never really went away and that
thanks to an old friend
his profile may soon be higher than ever
direct-to-video after his rocky for
success Lundgren found himself with no
shortage of offers he starred in 1987's
notoriously ramshackle Masters of the
Universe as he-man and was the first
big-screen incarnation of Marvel's
Punisher in 1989 but after 95 the big
screen offers seemed to dry up and
Lundgren spent the next decade and a
half working steadily in the types of
films he only used to see on the bargain
shelf at blockbuster
writer and director Lundgren's period
and director video a purgatory was not
without its professional rewards as it
happens he ended up behind the camera
purely by chance he explains to grant
land in 2002 or oh three this director
got sick before he was gonna direct me
in something when they went to replace
him he suggested me because I had worked
on the script with him I said really you
recommended me but I ended up directing
the movie that movie was 2004 the
defender and Lundgren has gone on to
write several more screenplays and
directed himself in five more features
he has multiple projects in the pipeline
as a director but he's not content to
stay behind the camera completely he's
also been quietly making a comeback in
mainstream Hollywood films who is the
most underrated actor of all time it's
Dolph Lundgren correct why well because
of his spiky hair has ice-cold demeanor
and his big muscles absolutely not so
expendable in 2010 Lundgren's 15 years
strake of non theatrical releases came
to a close with the Expendables which
brought together some of the greatest
action stars of the 80s for an
unapologetically throwback action film
in an interview with den of geek around
the time of the film's release
Lundgren said he'd been wondering if
he'd ever get to work with Stallone
again as the turret remained friends
ever since they punched the crap out of
each other in rocky for his Expendables
character the unhinged assassin gaana
Jensen ended up being among his
favorites to play and he reprised the
role in the two sequels television time
since returning to Hollywood Lundgren
has also taken on a number of one-shot
and recurring roles in various
television series beginning with a small
part in Chuck in 2010 in 2013 he was
cast as a lead in the syndicated TV
series safe while well received the
Baywatch style series only
20 episodes more recently Lundgren has
appeared as himself in episodes of
Sanjay and Craig and workaholics why
does Dolph Lundgren want to do some dumb
health blood thing with us oh I don't
know maybe because he's a decent person
who wants to contribute to society
he's also picked up a recurring role as
Russian government agent Konstantin
Kovar on the CW's hit superhero series
arrow fit forever now Pastis 60th
birthday Lundgren still isn't the kind
of man you want to slap around this is
due to a lifetime of dedication to
fitness that began well before he became
a movie star he won two Karate titles in
the early 80s on his way to achieving a
third degree black belt thanks to an
insane training regimen that saw him
rising at 3 a.m. every morning for a
five-mile run before hitting the dojo
followed by hours of weightlifting then
even more karate decades later his
training routine is only slightly less
intense heavy on sandbags medicine balls
and dumbbells Lundgren prefers a
resistance based workout routine which
keeps him in Borrego like shape and an
age when most men are starting to think
about retirement
he even outlined his complete approach
to fitness in his 2014 book train like
an action hero be fit forever which
details his personal philosophy of
fitness based on martial arts yoga
strength training biochemical research
professional sports and over 40 starring
roles in classic action films which are
pretty decent qualifications
class dismissed
action activist the 2014 film skin trade
which Lundgren wrote and starred in
features him as an American police
officer who goes to Thailand to take
down a human trafficking ring the film
supporting cast includes martial arts
legend Tony Jaa iconic character actor
Ron Perlman and Peter Weller aka Robocop
but its subject matter is no joke for
Lundgren who's made it his mission to do
everything he can to call attention to
the issue of human trafficking he works
regularly with a Los Angeles non profit
cult coalition to abolish slavery and
trafficking most action stars can be
seen on the screen saving people from
the clutches of criminal gangs but
Lundgren may be the only one who's taken
up the pursuit in real life big return
Lundgren's perseverance professionalism
and outright likeability has paid off
sure he continues to appear in such
future non classics as sharknado 5
global swarming
but his return to the big screen was
received warmly enough that office
haven't ended with the expendable series
he joined the cast of James ones Desi
film entry
Aquaman as King Nereus and antagonist
who covets the title character's love
interest making a showdown with Jason
Momoa as Aquaman all but inevitable but
even more exciting is the news
surrounding the sequel to 2015's Creed
Stallone and Lundgren both dropped hints
in social media teasing the eventual
confirmation that Lundgren would be
returning to the role that made him
famous which makes sense given that the
storyline focuses on the fight between
Adonis Creed and Victor Drago Ivan Drago
son tying the burgeoning spin-off
franchise back in with the saga that
spawned
[Music]